o hsmm sax em harmonia meio veriam
acho que isso aí é com este é o que
revela agora que voltei a treinar bem e
adicione nada tinha de colocar aí a água
e vivemos numa economia de consumo a
economia de consumo que é alimentada
através da publicidade publicidade em
última instância pela frente convencer a
comprar um produto ou serviço e pode ser
feita de várias formas mas hoje vamos
ficar naquela crise pra mim dizer
urgentemente ser mudada
aquela que faz com comidas de oito anos
como alex se sintam inseguras em relação
a si próprios porque o vídeo do jogo
estarei aqui não é único é um dos
milhares de vídeos que circulam pela
internet é um problema que precisa ser
resolvido vamos falar veículos cidade
respirar sinal
[Música]
em lowell thomas larga apenas a
publicidade aspiracional mostrando as
imagens nos levam a criar nossa
imaginação uma fantasia que se
comprarmos um certo produto
vamos ser iguais ao museu que está a
vender ou viver a vida que ela aparenta
ter e este um deus para além de terem
deles praticamente impossíveis de
alcançar ainda levam muitas vezes com
photoshop em cima pra aparecer ainda
mais prefeito
[Música]
a publicidade aspiracional visa explorar
o nosso desejo
seremos mais bonitos sexy sou ricos
acima tudo elementos das nossas
incertezas e das nossas inseguranças do
nosso medo não sermos bons o suficiente
e faz com que compramos coisas não
precisamos pressionar pessoas de que não
gostamos coisas que muitas vezes nem
sequer nos fazem ficar sequer presente
com de outros filmes a usar
não há nada que ela é que se possa
comprar nada que ela se possa usar nada
que ela é que no futuro possa
experimentar que faça ficar parecida com
esta mulher e por alexi esta mulher
depois de anos e anos publicidade
aspiracional com mulheres como esta o
como ela como mulher como esta é que é a
transmissão de doenças alexi e é
impossível é que se lá chegar
por que esta mulher não é real
esta nossa constante correria para
comprar e consumir produtos que nos
façam parceira melhores
aliado ao facto de os na maior parte das
vezes nem sequer nos deixarem como
modelo perfeito que vimos a vender não
só nos deixa tristes e frustrados como
nos destrói a autoestima
então mas coloca a importância da
autoestima
aliás por que é que serve a autoestima a
autoestima é o resultado da avaliação
subjetiva que fazemos nós próprios
subjetiva é o que nós achamos que nossas
próprias o que pode e é muitas vezes de
frente a realidade
então expliquei que era autoestima vamos
então imaginar uma lexie crescem
autoestima entre outras causas é causada
pela comparação como judeus prefeit
termos de publicidade operacional
o boletim sem autoestima é uma lei que
não faz aquilo que realmente quero
prometer julgamento do outro
por enquanto não temos autoestima são os
outros que definem por nós tornamos
dependendo de sua avaliação e aquilo que
vamos fazer
ou a pessoa que vai mexer não vai
encontrar aquilo que nós achamos que o
melhor para nós próprios não mas se vai
encontrar aquilo que achamos que os
outros esperam nós nós vamos fazer então
não
o que queremos mas aquilo que achamos
que os outros querem que nós fazemos
e esta leve sem autoestima vai pedir uma
vida em que não vai fazer o que eu
realmente quero nem as coisas que
realmente gosta
além disso o moleque sem autoestima é um
moleque com crenças limitativas é um
moleque que já se conta uma história
tantas vezes quantas vezes que não é
bonito o suficiente sexo suficiente
inteligente o suficiente rico o
suficiente se tornou na sua identidade
jett identidades subjetiva criada
subjetiva porque é assim que ele é que
se pressiona e não a realidade faz com
que ela disse não acreditar em si
própria e select não acreditar em si
própria não vai correr riscos porque nem
sequer se a impressora das recompensas
porque as coisas boas da vida não são
pessoas como ela a história que ela
conta ela própria
oito em cada dez mulheres diz que sente
pressão para nunca cometer erros ou
nunca mostrar fraqueza
pior ainda 85% das mulheres diz que não
vai experimentar um novo desporto ou uma
nova atividade não vai beber um copo com
os amigos ou não vai é uma instituição
importante familiar nesse dia não sentir
bem com sua aparência o que nós nos
limitamos com isto e vamos imaginar
então que ela é que se cresce a
autoestima e vamos imaginar que ela
disse achar que não é inteligente o
suficiente
como é que vai ser a sua confiança numa
sala de aula quando tiver que fazer uma
apresentação o professor
o próximo a ir turma como é que vai ser
a sua confiança numa primeira entrevista
de emprego ou a sua confiança numa
reunião importante em que ela disse sabe
o que é que tem que dizer mas como acha
que não é inteligente o suficiente não
vai dizer quando é que vai ser o
standard dalexi em relação à carreira
onde é ter um daquelas vai atirar
vamos imaginar que ela é que se cresce a
autoestima porque acha que não é bonita
o suficiente
o sesi suficiente como é que vai ser a
sua confiança com os rapazes da briga
como é que vai ser o seu primeiro
encontro o seu primeiro país a sua
primeira relação
vai ser uma lance com ciúmes uma leve e
segura de si própria
vai ser uma lexie vai atirar para a
melhor pessoa
a seguir o que vai contentar com a
primeira que conseguir encontrar essa
história nós nos encontramos encontramos
nas próprias
estas crianças limitativas aliadas ao
julgamento o outro fazem com que o ex-pm
toda a sua existência porque ultimamente
somos nós nos limitamos e nunca vamos
além dos limites que nos impomos agora
vocês podem estar a pensar que vai
cuidar da galaxy até podem estar a
sentir pena dela até podem estar a
pensar ainda bem que não são os meus
filhos e minha mulher eu não brigo os
meus pais e os meus irmãos
ainda bem que não sou o próprio alex não
é só uma criança de oito anos não é que
não é só do sexo feminino
alexi não é sobre cana
alexi somos todos nós estimado em 85 por
cento da população mundial sofre falta
de autoestima está a comprometer a nossa
felicidade
a publicidade tem um papel
importantíssimo neste mundo muito mais
do que um papel econômico tem um papel
social
eu não acredito em publicidade no xperia
final mas sim em publicidade
inspiracional ensinava com pessoas reais
com pessoas que não nos façam sentir
inseguros que acrescentem valor como com
pessoas que nos desafia a ir mais longe
que eles façam o que cheira que eles
façam acreditar que é possível aos
cargos ou nós queremos pessoas
autênticas é viver a vida pelas suas
próprias regras e que nos façam perceber
que talvez nós também conseguimos fazer
aquilo que queremos viver a vida e pelas
nossas próprias regras de publicidade
que faça com creche o exchange com
confiança e segurança em si próprias sem
medo do julgamento do outro sem crenças
limitativas e com coragem pra viver a
vida que realmente querem
eu acredito num futuro em que a
publicidade não desfaça aspirar a ser
como os outros mas nos inspira ser a
melhor versão mais próprias porque somos
tão melhor do que eu pensamos por que
estamos aqui uma vez uma vez está na
altura de percebermos de que o que nos
diferencia é que o que nos torna únicos
eu que faz nós pessoas especiais e é
sobre isso que devemos construir e
capitalizar e não esconder parece ter
opções sociais porque o futuro é agora
está na altura percebemos quem somos
aceitarmos quem somos e vivermos quando
ninguém estiver se ver obrigado
[Aplausos]